bah là je me sens bien je joue vraiment
le joue tous les soirs donc ces
quotidiens donc je parlais pas de
travail parce que ces élections baettig
est pas bon
le pape a en fait je dors très très peu
la nuit donc là je suis vraiment exténué
mais je vais jouer une détente 100 à 130
me prend la date mais j'ai ma guitare je
sais pas trop ce sujet faire avec la
plus ou moins décidée en tête bonjour
c'est norman pour brut
[Musique]
mon nouveau spectacle s'appelle le
spectacle de la maturité
c'est mon deuxième ces machos faire
marrer ses albums de rock ça fait
l'album de la maturité
ah bon c'est noble a connu un dia
toujours abandonnées où l'artiste il
sort un truc qui s'appelle le truc de la
maturité donc je voulais absolument
faire ça ça me faisait marrer et en même
temps est un petit peu de vérité parce
que ce serait que ça fait maintenant
huit ans je suis dit vidéo sur youtube
j'ai souvent été vu comme le
l'adulescent avec son chat dans sa
chambre
souvent un peu étiquetés comme ça est
bon ça me va très bien mais maintenant
j'ai quand même trente deux ans
maintenant je suis je suis père de
famille de rien c'est certes dire ça
mais c'est la vérité
donc c'était aussi une manière de voilà
de faire un petit clin d'oeil à aux gens
pour leur dire que j'ai voulu quoi moi
je kiffe pas la violence jamais aimé la
violence j'ai toujours préféré à la
violence la lâcheté et ibis et ton parti
arrivé normal elle moi là je réfléchis
plus c'est l'animal en moi qui parle et
cet animal c'est un chevreuil qui me dit
que j'ai commencé les vidéos sur youtube
quand j'avais 23 ans et c'est vrai qu'on
on a un petit trait comme comme
adolescent alors que j'en avais déjà 23
donc j'avais quand même déjà fait des
études j'étais j'avais déjà un métier
j'avais fait plein de petits jobs
j'étais déjà monteur vidéo
ouais je ne sais pas une adolescence
facile ça c'est clair et net
chacun son histoire donc voilà on n'est
pas la fois comparée à l'histoire de
chacun mais dans ma tête j'avais déjà un
petit bout de chemin qui a été fait donc
peut-être que l'image comme en commun
donné c'était pas celle que nous
correspondait vraiment au fond de moi
donc j'ai peut-être grandi rapidement
c'est après quand j'ai connu un petit
succès sur youtube j'ai vite eu des
contrats habitudes et des connexions
avec des gens et puis un coup j'ai été
proches aidants du jour au lendemain
dans un un peu un tourbillon quoi est-ce
que c'est laid le business des réseaux
sociaux et des médias on va sortir c'est
un vrai business 1 voilà quoi et c'est
ça tu es obligé de grandir avec sa de
fer avec toi donc c'est je pense qu'en
effet un décalage entre ce que les gens
pensaient de moi est ce que j'étais quoi
je suis très heureux et très fiers nous
annoncer que ça y est je suis papa je
suis pas [ __ ] c'est un truc de ouf je
sais même pas par où commencer tellement
le truc qui est énorme ça a changé
beaucoup de choses
intimement pour l'homme ou jeu ça ça met
un petit rayon de soleil dans ma vie
c'est un truc de fou
je ne sais pas comment on peut chacun sa
vision chaque papa est différent chaque
parent est différent mais c'est un
bonheur total
je travaille le matin tu attends comme
ça dans le berceau en disant papa
ces tickets surtout de mieux que ça
c'est le mineur est venu au monde donc
ça c'est évidemment génial
même si sa demande pour le travail je
crois que jamais été aussi heureux toute
ma vie j'en suis sûre même à bravo la
maman qui a participé beaucoup au projet
quand même bon aujourd'hui la nuit 1
au moins ça justifie mes cernes pour une
fois pour moi c'est vrai que j'ai perdu
ma mère jeunes comme beaucoup de gens
malheureusement qui perdent un parent
tôt dans leur vie et c'est vrai que ça
crée un manque pas créer un manque sur
effectif et c'est vrai que le fait de
devenir papa ça aussi une résonance
particulière dans ma vie quoi ça sert
d'avoir recréer quelque chose que
j'avais perdu ça m'a un peu comblé d'un
amour aussi qui dont j'ai peut-être
besoin depuis depuis longtemps quoi donc
sais c'est pas rien quand on sait comme
une transformation ma priorité c'est
vraiment ma famille ma fille tu vois et
mes films ce que j'ai une belle fille
aussi je considère mes mais mes
disciplines artistiques comme un peu
très importante mais secondaire quoi et
c'était pas le cas avant j'ai deux jours
et nuits que là dessus que sur mes
vidéos et parfois ça me je les lis
vétroz quand ça se passait mal j'étais
trop stressée quand ça se passait bien
évidemment j'ai et ça me
ça m'a obsédé en fait j'étais obsédé
donc je me suis un peu détendu avec avec
la création et ça fait vraiment du bien
ça fait vraiment du bien sûr que ça doit
être ça je me sens vivant en fait je me
sens vivant et ce que je fais ça
ressemble plus à un métier qu'avant
[ __ ] on a beau dire quand on est blanc
on n'a pas le droit à l'erreur
on n'a pas le droit au moindre dérapage
moi je le vois plus beaux tournois des
fois on se fait des blagues ans bruno tu
veux on change méchante je peux pas
aller aussi loin que dans la blague
je m'arrêtais un petit peu avant il ya
peu de temps avec mon pote hornoy sur la
plage il fait [ __ ] mais quoi de plus
de l'eau commente cachet d'aspirine away
entente et noir laisse tomber les
retombées pour être honnête je pense que
sur scène je suis beaucoup beaucoup plus
vrai beaucoup plus moi même et beaucoup
plus matures que dans les vidéos youtube
sur la scène je peux dire un truc un
petit peu subversif au second degré par
exemple dans mon nouveau spectacle a
ordonné à je fais une petite pause et je
dis bon maintenant une blague sur les
noirs et tout le monde rigole parce que
tout le monde est avec moi et comprend
ce second degré qu'on pourra avoir dans
la vie tu vois alors que sur youtube
warning interdiction de dire ceci oui à
brut s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
j'espère qu'il fera un bon sujet sur moi
ni le floch instruments ouais le arrêt
forcé ma base c'est vrai qu'en ce moment
j'ai besoin d'avoir plein drôle en même
temps le rôle de papa en priorité est
évidemment le rôle de oi de vidéastes
sur youtube le rôle d'humoriste sur
scène c'est vrai que bon ben voilà c'est
un peu un un tunnel de travail en ce
moment mais je n'ai pas le droit de me
plaindre je fais vraiment le les plus
beaux métiers du monde lui tombe bien la
cigale à partir du 10 décembre pendant
quelques mois je serai ans
a tous je ne sais plus je crois c'est un
zénith ward ça au zénith de toulouse
bien joué je me trompe pas
promo de rup street c'est trop beau en
fait tu connais un peu le concept assez
les grèves ont pas autant
[Musique]